.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Hier ist der Eingang.
Irgendwo hier ist das Gästezimmer.
Und hier ... Ist hier die Küche?
Oder hier?
- Nein, da.
Hier, oder?
- Ja.
Von hier aus trinken wir dann
unseren Frühstückskaffee.- Genau.
Karin und Stefan Bolliger
wollen nach Litauen auswandern.
Ihr Traum von einer Ferienanlage
startet mit viel Schwung
und droht bald zu platzen.
Wenn man von Anfang an wüsste,
was auf einen zukommt,
hätte man viel zu viel Angst,
um überhaupt zu starten.
Das ist die Geschichte
einer Auswanderung
mit vielen Hochs und Tiefs.
Den nächsten machst du.
- Ja.
So.
Karin Bolliger arbeitet
bei der Kantonspolizei Zürich,
ihr Mann Stefan
ist Abteilungsleiter in einer Firma
für Sicherheitstechnik.
Sie haben in Litauen
ein grosses Stück Land gekauft,
mit dem sie
noch grössere Pläne haben.
Die Endvision ist schon,
dass es Wege,
Blumen und einzelne Bäume hat.
Es soll wie ein Park werden.
So kann man auf einem Weg
dem See entlangflanieren
und den Sonnenuntergang geniessen.
Und man kann
so richtig zur Ruhe kommen,
wie sowieso in Litauen.
- Mhm.
Was für ein Gefühl
habt ihr im Moment?
Es ist unbeschreiblich.
Es ist so viel Zeit vergangen,
in der nichts lief.
Man denkt immer, es gehe vorwärts,
aber dann passiert doch nichts.
Und plötzlich passiert jetzt etwas.
Es ist sichtbar.
Wir verbrachten so viele Stunden
auf dem Grundstück,
bei jeder Gelegenheit.
Allein. Und plötzlich
sind Leute hier, die etwas machen.
Ja, es ist unbeschreiblich.
Mhm.
Gefällt es dir so, Karin?
- Super.
Hm?
Von hier aus sieht man den See.
Das ist gut.
Ja, es fühlt sich megagut an.
Ich habe Glücksgefühle.
- Ja, es ist ...
Ich bin froh, dass wir das ...
* Flüstern *
* Lachen *
Mal schauen, wann wir
das erste Bier servieren können.
Es stellt sich die Frage,
wie die Bolligers darauf kommen,
nach Litauen - in ein kleines Land
im Baltikum - auszuwandern.
Und wieso sie ausgerechnet hier,
in der Region Anyksciai,
rund zwei Autostunden
von der Hauptstadt Vilnius entfernt -
also ziemlich abgelegen -,
eine Ferienanlage bauen wollen.
Nun: Angefangen hat alles
auf einer Motorradtour.
Plötzlich hatte ich den Gedanken.
Er war sehr stark und intensiv.
Er war ganz simpel.
Es hiess einfach:
"Ich will hier wohnen."
Ich hinterfragte den Gedanken stark.
Ich kannte solche Gedanken
gar nicht,
plötzlich das Gefühl zu haben,
ich wolle hier wohnen.
Ich wusste nicht,
wie ich das einordnen soll.
Aber das war so stark
und wirklich wichtig.
Ich suchte den Fotoapparat
aus meiner Tasche raus
und machte beim Vorbeifahren
ein Foto von dieser Tafel,
damit ich mich daran erinnere,
wo das ist.
Und ja ...
... das war megaspeziell.
Das war der Moment, der Gedanke,
der alles in Bewegung brachte,
was wir jetzt hier machen.
Das faszinierte mich total.
Etwas Natur, etwas ...
... abgelegen,
Action, ein anderes Land,
etwas Eigenes haben und aufbauen ...
Ich fing sofort an zu träumen
und fing Feuer für die Sache.
Seither lodert das Auswanderungsfeuer
bei den Bolligers.
Sie haben Land gesucht und gefunden.
Sie haben
eine Ferienanlage konzipiert
und Businesspläne entwickelt.
Und sie haben
alle nötigen Bewilligungen eingeholt,
um mit dem Bau zu beginnen.
Die Bolligers
sind nach Vilnius gefahren.
Sie wollen eine Baumesse besuchen,
um viele Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Begleitet werden sie
von ihrem Bauführer Ramunas,
der ihnen helfen soll, sich
in diesen unendlichen Möglichkeiten
einen Überblick zu verschaffen.
Wenn man viel darauf läuft,
wetzt sich das wohl ab.
Ja. Und Dreck und so. Das kann man
gar nicht richtig putzen.
Böden, Fliesen, Heizungen, Fenster -
überall haben sie die Qual der Wahl.
Diese Dichtung
finde ich nicht so schlau.
Fass sie mal an.
Gibt es ein klares Budget
für all das, was ihr macht,
oder seid ihr da flexibel?
Bis zu einem gewissen Punkt
sind wir flexibel.
Aber man achtet schon darauf,
dass man es ...
Man kann immer noch nach oben gehen.
Reduzieren ist immer schwieriger.
Aber gewisse Dinge
sind einfach wichtig.
Fenster usw.
müssen von der Qualität her stimmen,
sonst stimmt
unser ganzes Konzept nicht.
Da sind wir bereit, mehr auszugeben.
Und bei anderen Dingen, die man ...
... im Nachhinein
noch anpassen kann,
kann man anfangs auch mal
etwas Günstigeres nehmen.
Wie gross ihr Budget genau ist,
wollen die Bolligers nicht verraten.
Mit den Flügeltüren
kann man alles aufmachen.
Und bei Schiebetüren
verliert man immer einen Teil.
Klar ist:
Sie stecken ihre Ersparnisse plus
Pensionskassengelder in ihren Traum.
1 m oder 1,30 m
macht schon einen Unterschied.
Es ist wie Weihnachten, oder?
Wir müssen uns
noch nicht entscheiden.
Wir verschaffen uns einen Überblick
und schätzen ein bisschen ab,
was wir wollen.
Gewisse Dinge wissen wir schon,
anderes braucht noch Zeit.
Aber im Moment
hat es noch Platz im Hirn.
Manchmal sprengt es
schon ein bisschen den Kopf,
wenn man all die Dinge ...
... umsetzen will.
Man fragt sich, ob man vielleicht
etwas falsch überlegt hat.
Kann man es dann noch ändern?
Wird es einem gefallen?
Wird es den Leuten gefallen?
Es ist schwierig.
Abends bin ich sicher müde
von den ganzen Überlegungen.
Du kannst dich auch hinlegen.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
ahnen die Bolligers noch nicht,
was alles auf sie zukommen wird.
Es ist eine Zeit des Träumens
und des Wünschens.
Wo sollte das Projekt
in fünf Jahren sein,
wenn ihr euch das wünschen könntet?
Wie sieht euer Leben aus?
Unser Leben?
Unser Guesthouse ist aufgebaut.
Es sollte zusätzliche Cabins
oder Bungalows haben.
Es sollte einen schönen Steg haben.
Und wir sollten Angestellte haben.
Das Personal soll eingespielt sein.
Die Sommersaison
ist ab April ausgebucht.
Wir möchten
vom Geschäft leben können.
Es soll sich entwickeln
und nicht stehen bleiben.
Was in unseren Köpfen ist,
soll greifbar und lebbar werden.
(Beide) Mhm.
- Ja.
Wir sollten die Sprache können.
Wir sollten fliessend Litauisch
sprechen und uns integriert haben,
mit den lokalen Leuten sprechen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
So?
- Ja.
Das sieht schön aus.
Im Moment haben die Bolligers
noch keinen festen Ort zum Schlafen,
darum sind sie
mit einem Wohnwagen hierhergekommen,
den sie auf dem Grundstück
von litauischen Bekannten
abstellen dürfen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Man merkt schnell,
dass man gar nicht viel braucht.
Und es ist einem total wohl.
V.a., wenn es schön Wetter ist.
Dann ist man eh draussen.
Stefan hat seinen Job in der Schweiz
gekündigt, Karin noch nicht.
Sie arbeitet weiter
beim Forensischen Institut Zürich.
* Telefon *
Karin.
Hoi.
Hast du einen Auftrag für mich?
Wenn irgendwo im Kanton Zürich
ein Verbrechen begangen wird,
dann rückt sie aus.
Ihr Auftrag: vor Ort Spuren sichern.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Also.
Ob der Brand in dieser Tiefgarage
mit Absicht gelegt wurde, ist unklar.
Die Ermittlungen werden zeigen,
ob hier wirklich
ein Verbrechen vorliegt.
Ich schaue etwas rum,
weil ich vielleicht was sehe,
das noch niemandem aufgefallen ist.
Es ist immer besser,
wenn mehrere Augen schauen.
Ein Alltag wie im Krimi,
den sie über alles liebt.
Darum fällt es ihr schwer,
ihre Arbeit aufzugeben.
Ausserdem haben die Bolligers
so weiter ein sicheres Einkommen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Hm?
Die Bolligers wohnen idyllisch:
in Hüntwangen -
zusammen mit zwei Alpakas,
die irgendwann ebenfalls
nach Litauen umziehen sollen.
Es ist ein Privileg,
so leben zu dürfen.
Tiere und Natur gehen ins Herz.
Das tut einem einfach gut.
Stefan ist inzwischen die meiste Zeit
in Litauen und beaufsichtigt den Bau,
kommt aber immer wieder zu Besuch.
Karin ist meist hier,
aber auch immer wieder in Litauen.
Ihr Haus in Hüntwangen
wollen sie vorerst behalten -
für den Fall der Fälle.
Vier Monate nach Baubeginn hat
sich in Litauen bereits viel getan.
Für die Bolligers
läuft alles nach Plan.
In einer ersten Phase soll nun
ein Guesthouse mit fünf Zimmern
und einem Restaurant entstehen.
Das Grundstück der Bolligers
liegt in einer Gegend,
die beliebt ist bei Städtern,
die hier Ruhe und Erholung suchen.
Es gibt ein paar schöne Dinge
in der Gegend.
Aber natürlich nicht so viele.
Es hat drei, vier
schönere Unterkünfte oder Hotels,
würde ich sagen.
Und ein paar kleinere.
Aber direkt am See hat es nur eines.
- Ja, in dieser Gegend.
Mit anderen Worten:
Es gibt noch kaum Angebote,
aber eine grosse Nachfrage.
Also optimale Voraussetzungen, um
mit ihrem Geschäft Erfolg zu haben.
Die Bolligers
haben ein ganzes Team angestellt,
das für den Bau des Guesthouses
zuständig ist und gut vorankommt.
Trotzdem ziehen dunkle Wolken auf.
Denn ihnen
droht schon bald das Geld auszugehen.
Ja, kurz gesagt:
Wir sind gut gestartet.
Dann floss gewisses Geld,
das hätte fliessen sollen ...
... einfach nicht,
obwohl das eigentlich sicher war.
Momentan ist das sicher ...
... ein grosses Hindernis.
Daran knabbern wir gerade.
Das bereitet uns schon Sorgen. Mhm.
Wir haben nicht nur uns gegenüber
eine Verantwortung,
sondern auch für unsere Mitarbeiter.
Wenn ich daran denke ...
... ihnen sagen zu müssen,
dass wir sie
nicht weiter beschäftigen können,
gibt mir das einen Stich ins Herz.
Wir sehen die Leute jeden Tag,
freuen uns über sie ...
Sie arbeiten super.
Man hat einen Bezug zu ihnen.
- Mhm.
Und unsere Pläne
rücken so natürlich ...
... weiter in die Ferne.
So kann man zeitlich
nicht genau sagen, wann es klappt.
Mhm.
Man muss gewisse Risiken eingehen
und einfach mal starten.
Wenn man von Anfang an wüsste,
was auf einen zukommt,
hätte man viel zu viel Angst,
um überhaupt zu starten.
Wir als Schweizer sowieso.
Wir brauchen drei Versicherungen,
um irgendetwas zu machen.
Wie lange die Bolligers
ihren Arbeitern den Lohn
noch zahlen können, ist unklar.
Und auch wie es mit dem Projekt
insgesamt weitergeht, ist offen.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Oder ob wir es nebeneinander wollen.
- Wir sehen uns die Punkte an,
die wir updaten müssen,
und ich schreibe es auf.
Einen Hoffnungsschimmer
gibt es allerdings:
Sie sind mit einem litauischen
Investor in Kontakt gekommen.
Der stellt ihnen
grosse Summen in Aussicht,
möchte aber
einen überarbeiteten Businessplan.
Bei den Bolligers
keimt wieder Hoffnung auf.
Nur eine Seite.
Wir müssen darauf achten,
dass es unsere Vision, unsere
Vorstellung und unser Traum bleibt.
Es soll nicht jemand dazukommen,
der ganz andere Vorstellungen hat
und uns zur Seite drängt.
Wir sind stark fokussiert darauf,
das zu erhalten.
Es sieht aber sehr gut aus
mit dem Partner,
den wir in Aussicht haben.
Er scheint uns machen zu lassen
und ...
... unterstützt uns einfach.
Ja.
Einen Monat später steht
die Baustelle der Bolligers still,
denn ihr Bauleiter hat ein Burn-out.
Und vom Investor kommt kein Geld.
Stefan wohnt inzwischen in einer Art
Tiny House auf dem Grundstück
und versucht verzweifelt, einen neuen
Bauleiter und Geld zu organisieren.
Karin und ich
denken viele Szenarien durch.
Was machen wir,
wenn das nicht passiert?
Wie machen wir es,
wenn jenes nicht funktioniert?
Es ist immer
ein bisschen eine Anspannung da.
Wie geht es weiter?
Wann geht es weiter?
Kann man das lösen?
Gibt es einen Ausweg?
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit?
Stefan ist derzeit allein in Litauen.
Karin ist zurück in die Schweiz
gereist, um dort zu arbeiten.
Der Winter steht vor der Tür.
Bevor der Schnee kommt,
müssen die Bolligers versuchen,
das Dach fertig zu bekommen
und Wände hochzuziehen,
sonst könnte das
bereits verbaute Holz Schaden nehmen.
Es hält schon etwas aus,
aber es ist wichtig ...
... dass es für den Winter
gedeckt ist.
Rein schon vom Frost her.
Das Holz muss geschützt sein.
Die Balken
sind eigentlich schon fertig.
Sie sind so behandelt, dass man sie
dann im Gebäude auch sieht.
Und ...
Sie sind
mit schwarzem Plastik abgedeckt,
damit sie keinen Schaden nehmen.
Es ist wichtig,
dass wir bis zum ersten Schnee ...
... und bis der Winter kommt,
der bald da ist,
das Dach decken können.
Um die Baustelle am Laufen zu halten,
brauchen die Bolligers
dringend liquide Mittel,
ansonsten
wird kein Baumaterial mehr geliefert
und die Arbeiter bleiben zu Hause.
Vielleicht ist der Traum von einer
Ferienanlage schon bald geplatzt.
Das Projekt
steht nun definitiv am Scheideweg.
Trotzdem lernt Stefan weiter
fleissig Litauisch.
Er sieht seine Zukunft hier
und versucht positiv zu bleiben,
aber gleichzeitig auch realistisch.
Der Worst Case wäre, das Dach
vor dem Winter nicht hinzukriegen.
Dann würde ich selber hochklettern
und Plastik darüberlegen.
Man müsste dann irgendwie ...
... wieder ein Notfallszenario
machen.
Je weniger man daran glaubt,
desto schneller kommen Zweifel.
Aber auch wenn es so wäre,
hätten wir es wenigstens versucht.
Das haben wir auch immer gesagt:
"Es ist ein Risiko,
aber wir versuchen es."
"Was wäre,
wenn wir 65 oder 70 sind ...
... und sagen müssten, dass wir es
aus Angst nicht versucht haben?"
Das wäre auch ...
Das würde uns auch nicht gefallen.
Ein halbes Jahr später in Hüntwangen.
Es ist Frühling geworden
und die Bolligers packen.
Sie wollen ihre Zelte in der Schweiz
nun abbrechen
und nach Litauen auswandern.
Dank Darlehen von Verwandten
und einem geheimnisvollen
Schweizer Investor,
der im Dunkeln bleiben will,
ist es ihnen gelungen,
das Projekt zu retten
und ihr Guesthouse einen entschei-
denden Schritt voranzubringen.
Die Fassade ist fertig.
Es hat sich wirklich
zum Guten gewendet.
Wir fanden Investoren
und Darlehensgeber.
Und ...
Das hat sich im Januar entwickelt.
Im Januar hatte ich mal so richtig
das Gefühl, ich könne ...
... nach Litauen gehen,
ohne immer diesen Druck zu haben.
Wir konnten uns mal wieder auf
die Zukunft konzentrieren und ...
... auf die wichtigen Aufgaben
wie den Bau und das Organisieren.
Das ... Ja ... Und dann ...
Das ...
Das Wissen,
dass es jetzt weitergeht,
wir das Haus fertigbauen und im
Juni oder Juli eröffnen können ...
Aber dann kam das Coronavirus
und zwang die Welt in Lockdowns
und Shutdowns.
Grenzen wurden geschlossen und
das öffentliche Leben lahmgelegt -
und zwar just in dem Moment,
in dem die Bolligers von der Schweiz
nach Litauen ziehen wollten.
Das zu akzeptieren,
ist etwas schwierig.
Wir haben versucht,
eine andere Möglichkeit zu finden,
um es doch noch hinzukriegen.
Denn ...
Ja ...
Es ist so kurz vor dem Ziel,
auf das wir so lange gewartet
und das wir
so oft durchgespielt haben.
Der Abnabelungsprozess
war für mich auch ziemlich lange.
Dass ich ... Ja ...
Ich freute mich wirklich
und war bereit, um zu gehen.
Und jetzt
gibt es wieder einen Stopp.
Es ist schwierig,
das zu akzeptieren.
Ich weiss nicht,
was ich vielleicht noch brauche.
Brauche ich noch etwas
oder doch nicht?
Sonst kann alles in die Garage.
Bis auf Weiteres
leben sie zwischen Kisten.
Gute zwei Monate später
hat das Warten ein Ende.
Die Kisten werden endlich bewegt.
Das bleibt auch hier.
Die Grenzen sind passierbar
und die Bolligers
wollen die Gunst der Stunde nutzen
und den Umzug über die Bühne bringen,
bevor sich die Situation
wieder ändert.
Wie ist die Stimmung jetzt?
Ähm ...
Es ist schwierig, das zu definieren.
Wir haben jetzt
wirklich lange gewartet.
Es war einfach sehr ungewiss,
wann es definitiv weitergeht.
Wir mussten mittendrin aufhören
und dann im Chaos zurechtkommen.
Jetzt sind wir megafroh,
dass es vorwärtsgeht
und wir endlich gehen können.
Ja, wir sind sehr froh.
Oben hat es noch viel Ware.
Familie und Freunde sind gekommen,
um die Bolligers
beim Umzug zu unterstützen.
Oh!
Okay. Ich kann nicht beide nehmen.
Ist der gleich schwer?
- Alles ist schwer.
Nein, der ist leichter.
Das ist leicht.
- Das nehme ich.
Ihr dürft zwischendurch
auch mal was Leichtes tragen.
Jetzt wird es ernst.
Ich bin seit drei Wochen
nervös darüber,
ob mit den Fahrzeugen,
dem Lastwagen usw. alles klappt.
Und jetzt, ob wirklich alles Platz
hat und wir alles hineinbringen.
Es ist megacool,
dass so viele Leute helfen.
Aber alle haben fragen:
"Was muss runter?"
"Was muss ich machen?"
Ich bin etwas angespannt.
Man hat das Ziel vor Augen.
Heute Abend ist es wieder anders.
Wenn wir mit dem Bier
draussen sitzen, ist gut.
Ihr Haus wollen sie behalten,
um es zu vermieten.
Zuerst wird nun aber ein ganzes Leben
in einen riesigen Lastwagen verladen
und auf die rund 1'800 km lange Reise
Richtung Osten geschickt.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ein weiteres Jahr
ist ins Land gegangen.
Palaima, so heisst die Ferienanlage
der Bolligers nun.
Sie ist nach fünf Jahren Planung
und Bau inzwischen eröffnet,
das Guesthouse in Betrieb.
Und Stefan ist gerade daran,
das Frühstück für die Gäste
vorzubereiten.
Die Köche
werden erst gegen Mittag eintreffen,
darum muss der Chef die Gipfeli
selbst in den Ofen schieben.
Karin und ich springen ...
... dort ein,
wo es noch jemanden braucht.
Ich bin ein bisschen
in diese Rolle reingerutscht -
als Frühstücksmacher.
Ich helfe mit.
Das habe ich dreckig gemacht.
Im dritten Monat nach der Eröffnung
ist das kleine Guesthouse
mit seinen fünf Zimmern
bereits zu 70 % ausgelastet.
Als der Betrieb startete ...
... gab es anfangs noch Dinge,
die sich einpendeln mussten.
Es kamen von allen Seiten Fragen:
"Stefan, Karin, wie geht das?"
Jetzt pendelt es sich aber ein.
* Alarm *
Wir versuchen,
unsere freien Tage zu haben.
Und alle im Team wissen,
was sie machen müssen.
Die Küche und das Restaurant
funktionieren sowieso super.
Ich kann wirklich sagen, dass es ...
... so ist,
wie wir uns das vorgestellt hatten.
Es gibt mehr zu tun,
als man sich vorstellt,
aber das ist wohl überall so.
Ziel erreicht, sagen die Bolligers.
Sie hätten
eine Wohlfühloase geschaffen.
Ein kleines, aber feines Hideaway
für Geniesser und Naturliebhaber -
inmitten von wunderschöner Natur,
direkt am See gelegen.
Karin verbringt den Sommer hier und
unterstützt die fünf Angestellten.
Ihren Job in der Schweiz hat sie
allerdings noch nicht aufgegeben.
Bis auf Weiteres
will sie über den Winter
jeweils bei der Kantonspolizei Zürich
als Forensikerin im Einsatz sein.
Im Moment bin ich hier
und es gefällt mir sehr gut.
Ja.
Aber kaum bin ich in der Schweiz
und komme ins Büro rein ...
... fühle ich mich
einfach total wohl.
Es ist ein bisschen ... Genau.
Es sind zwei verschiedene Kulissen.
Aber was ich hier mache, mache ich
gerne und mit Leidenschaft.
Und das
bei der Polizei in der Schweiz auch.
Nach dem Frühstück bereitet Karin die
Zimmer für die nächsten Gäste vor.
Dass sie ihren Job in der Schweiz
noch nicht gekündigt hat,
hat damit zu tun,
dass sie ihn liebt - aber nicht nur.
Das Guesthouse
ist zwar gut gestartet,
aber wer weiss,
ob sie nicht plötzlich wieder froh
um ein sicheres Einkommen sind.
Es gibt immer einen Weg.
Aber wenn man einen Hafen hat,
ist das sehr beruhigend.
Wollen die Investoren
langsam Geld zurück?
Das kommt nächstes Jahr.
Bis jetzt ...
... ist das eigentlich
noch nicht akut bzw. aktuell.
Aber dann ... Ja, das wird
ab nächstem Jahr ein Thema.
Aber wenn es
so weitergeht wie jetzt:
Es kommt immer etwas Geld rein.
Wir können nicht nur
die Löhne bezahlen, sondern ...
... auch etwas mehr.
Daher ist es momentan gut.
Aber es muss das ganze Jahr
so weitergehen.
Dann kommt das gut.
Dann kommt das schon gut.
Momentan
sind wir über dem geplanten Budget -
im positiven Bereich.
Das ist natürlich sehr erfreulich
und bringt etwas Luft und Ruhe.
Ja.
Aber es ist noch nicht
auf einem Niveau,
auf dem ihr euch einen normalen Lohn
auszahlen könntet.- Nein.
Nein, nein.
Das nicht.
Die Chefs kommen immer zuletzt dran.
Stefan ist neben dem Frühstück
v.a. auch für
die ganze Administration zuständig -
oft wochen- oder monatelang
ohne Karin,
die in die Schweiz zurückgeht.
Es ist kein Problem.
Das ist auch Einstellungssache.
Aber wir waren schon immer ...
... Personen, die ...
... unterschiedlich arbeiteten -
seit wir uns kennenlernten
und zusammenkamen.
Wir arbeiteten immer in Schichten.
Wir wussten immer,
wann wir Zeit füreinander haben.
Das ist Qualitätszeit
und sonst ist es anders.
Mit den heutigen Medien kann man
trotzdem viel kommunizieren.
Klar ist es schön, wenn wir zusammen
sind und zusammen Zeit verbringen.
Vorerst hat diese Geschichte
also ein Happy End.
Aber das Guesthouse
soll ja nur der Anfang sein.
In den kommenden Jahren
soll sich hier
eine ganze Ferienanlage entwickeln.
Seit fünf Jahren sind Bolligers
nun schon auf dieser Reise -
zusammen mit ihren Alpakas,
die inzwischen auch
in Litauen angekommen sind.
Auf einer Reise, die mit grossen
Plänen und viel Schwung begonnen hat.
Auf einer Reise
mit vielen Höhen und Tiefen -
und mit ungewissem Ausgang.
Was denkt ihr,
wo ihr in weiteren fünf Jahren steht?
Das ist eine interessante Frage.
Immer noch hier.
- Achtung, Hund.
Hoffentlich
mit einem fertigen Garten.- Genau.
Schön gepflegte Pflanzen, grössere
Bäume, die Schatten geben ...
Einen schönen Rasen vor dem Palaima.
Die Sauna ist fertig.
- Genau.
Vielleicht können wir
das Restaurant vergrössern.
Dann fehlen noch die Cabins ...
... und das Mainhouse.
Wir wollen
eine gesunde Grösse haben ...
... mit all dem,
was wir geplant haben.- Mhm.
Und weiterhin gute Angestellte.
Fünf Jahre gehen schnell vorbei.
- Ja.
Wenn man sich
die letzten fünf Jahre ansieht ...
Und wir möchten
auch wieder mal Zeit haben,
um Ferien zu machen.
- Ja, genau.
Das wäre schön. Etwas mehr Zeit,
um Motorrad zu fahren.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022